pues hasta el momento no se conoce una
reacción oficial por parte del gobierno
británico pero lo cierto es que ha sido
un día de mucha confusión de tensión
para los viajeros finalmente francia
esta noche anunciado que permitirá que
los ciudadanos británicos
viajen por su territorio por vía
terrestre si van a su casa en un país de
la unión europea durante las fiestas
pero como sabemos han sido más de 24
horas de mucha atención de confusión
sobre todo de los británicos que viven
en países europeos y quieren pasar las
fiestas de nuevo año aquí en el reino
unido- y tienden a viajar por ser una de
las rutas más fáciles por francia el
eurotúnel había dicho anoche que por ser
el reino unido ya un tercer país después
del break si no se permitía entonces ese
tránsito pero esto ya se ha aclarado si
se permitirá durante las fiestas esta
decisión de francia se perfilaba como
una nueva atención en esta ya larga
lista creciente de fricciones entre
boris johnson y emanuel